oh but now Forbes has released their
list for the world's 100 most powerful
women in 2022 and there are so many
women to celebrate on this list oh yes
so Kamala Harris made it to spot number
three on the list after becoming US vice
president which was followed by a lot of
Firsts for the position including first
black first woman and First South Asian
American to become U.S vice president
yes and of course there were a few
celebrities on the list including
Rihanna who came in spot number 73 for
her cosmetic line Fenty Beauty which has
helped her make her current net of
1.4 billion dollars that's according to
Forbes so we're never getting music okay
and following behind Rihanna in spot
number 79 is Taylor Swift Forbes says
that after releasing her album midnights
in October the singer became the first
artist in history to claim the top 10
spots on Billboard's Hot 100 song list
and I mean wow yeah incredible but I'm
sure we all have some pretty incredible
women in our lives so who do you
consider to be the most powerful woman
in your life Keisha oh definitely Mama
Shantae she is my biggest supporter and
she will snatch me so we say hello to
her and so much love yeah what about you
oh definitely Gabby my mom for sure we
have to say it to the moms right yes
this is so cute